- What is something
everyone looks stupid doing?
- Oh, like walking in a pool?
(laughter)
For sure.
- Yeah, that's dumb.
Like, who are you, Jesus?
(laughter)
- Sitting on a high stool or a
low chair.
- Yeah, that's dumb.
- I just know all of these
are all fat guy problems.
(laughter)
(guitar riff)
- What's up everybody?
I'm Chris Destefano,
this is called Stupid Questions,
I got Big Jay Oakerson you know
him
from Comedy Central Radio's 'The
Bonfire'.
And we're two straight white
males, what is this, 2011?
(electronic drums)
(laughter) Alright, what
would you rather have,
no nipples or no fingernails?
- (inhale) No nipples.
- Yeah.
- I'm a fingernail-biter.
- Sames.
- So, I love that.
- Yeah.
- I know it's destroying my
teeth day by day (laughter)
I love biting those nails.
Not a big fan of biting my own
nipples.
- I would love to have the
flexibility
to bite my own nipples though.
- You can get the flexibility
or you take my path
where you can get your tits
big enough to reach your mouth.
(laughter)
(guitar stab)
- Alright, another stupid
question.
Would you rather be the worst
player on a championship team
or the best player in the last
place team?
- I'd rather be the worst
player on a championship team--
- Really? You wanna win the
championship?
- Yeah, I mean when you
show the ring at the bar
you're still gonna get the same
love.
- That's true.
(laughter)
- If you always wear your
jersey they'll recognize you.
- I've been on so many last
place teams.
- I've also never been like,
there's two seconds
left, look in the crowd
and went: give me the ball.
(laughter)
I got this.
- I got this.
(guitar riff)
What set of items would you buy
that would make the
cashier most uncomfortable?
- I know what makes me most
uncomfortable
is never buying Magnum condoms.
(laughter)
'Cause they always point
at them first, like these?
They should let you buy
condoms on your own,
you shouldn't have to tell
someone which box that is.
(laughter)
- I was helping my Dad out, and
I bought,
I had to go in the same cashier,
I got my Dad's colonoscopy prep
medication
for the next day, and condoms
and the lady was like,
what the fuck, what's going on
tonight?
(laughter)
I was like, you don't even know,
lady.
Have you gotten a colonoscopy
yet?
- Not a colonoscopy--
- I have.
- Really?
- Oh yeah.
- I've had plenty of
doctor's fingers up my ass.
At least he said we was a
doctor.
(laughter)
(guitar stab)
- Alright bud. Do you have
a name for your penis?
- No.
- No?
- I've had a girl say the word
'chode',
watch we get one sad tear
forming
and then go: no it's a good
thing.
- Know what I call my penis?
Little Italy!
(laughter)
That's what it is!
(guitar stab)
Jay we both have daughters,
so what would you
rather have your daughter come
home with?
Would you rather have her come
home
with a professional athlete
or a professional singer?
- You know what? I'll say,
this is in my own interests,
I'm gonna go with musician,
rock star musician.
- Yeah.
- Because you could always
have access to that world then.
With sports, if it's not my home
team,
I don't want her dating someone
from
- Yeah.
- some other team that might
beat my team.
- Yeah, that's true.
- I don't want her dating like a
Piston.
- Yeah.
- Or a Houston Rocket.
- (grunts) Yeah, that's a good
point.
- What if I have to go
Cleveland for a playoff game?
(disgusted grunts)
(guitar stab)
- Alright Jay, thanks so much
for being a part of Stupid
Questions.
- Thank you for having me.
- You know, you're my boy,
I appreciate it you know.
I wanna give you a stupid gift.
- OK.
- Is that cool? I got two stupid
gifts 'cause you're my boy.
- I got so much room in my
stupid house for stupid gifts.
- First thing is, you always
wear fingerless gloves,
so toeless socks.
- What!
- There you go cuz, with the
grippings.
And then also, last time we were
hanging
you said that, you know,
you were like cutting carbs,
so I just got you hot dogs.
- Straight up hot dogs?
- Straight up just the meat,
cuz.
- Raw?
- Yeah, and we were also talking
a lot
about our penises today,
so I got you a second
bag of hot dogs.
- Oh, what!
- There you go, man.
- That's great.
- Is that stupid or what?
- Raw too, it's like baloney
sticks.
(laughter)
- Alright everybody,
thanks for hanging out,
it's been Stupid Questions
with Chris Destefano,
Big Jay Oakerson, Comedy
Central Radio's Sirius XM,
I appreciate you being here,
I gave you hot dogs and toeless
socks.
- Stupid fart.
- Good night.
(guitar stab)